[Music]
Justin Bieber steps out to support his
pal patrick Schwarzenegger at the
Midnight Sun movie premiere would it
like to have the support of him I know
you guys are good friends
ya know he's such a great guy and I'm
happy that he came to support I'll
support him throughout his life I'm just
really blessed to call him the friend
he's a really great guy the star power
didn't end there
Patrick's famous family was there too
his mom Maria Shriver and sisters
Katharine and Christina what is it like
to see your son becomes a man in
Hollywood is exciting for him so sweet
for him he's such a good young man so
proud grew up in a Hollywood elites
family what kind of advice do they give
you ahead of his projects I mean my mom
and my dad have given me advice on every
count whether that's being a son the
student a actor a businessman my dad and
mom always just want me to follow my
passion also in attendance the 24 year
old actors girlfriend Abby champion
Patrick is taking pictures with his
girlfriend Abby does she get mom's
approval yes I love Abby she's a
wonderful young woman she's terrific
[Music]
[Applause]